I used to be a spoiled child isolation
and Quarantine has made me do things for
myself which is very very disheartening
I didn't become famous to be doing
things for myself this is my idea of
Fame honestly you know in our office we
had a person who was considered a shoe
sure what is it they were in charge of
quieting down everyone while I was
meditating Robin was a big noise maker
and it was too much noise so we hired
the shooter the shoe sure got Sal and
Richard and control got Ronny under
control got Robin under control you
can't talk in here right no there's no
talking it was like a monastery and one
of the staff had their printer near my
wall so I through the wall I could hear
the printer and that would assure sure
was going and go you better [ __ ] turn
that off in the printer every day after
the show it couldn't even be used by
accident our shirt not only shushes but
she uses the finger she puts her finger
up to her mouth she gets right up into
you and she glares at you her eyes she
makes eye contact like I'm not [ __ ]
around
sure sure her computer faced the wall
but she says she had a mirror so she
could see behind her to see who in the
office was talking she does not play
games
JD you took the brunt of a lot of the
shushers uh well I was the original
sister and I just did not do a very good
job JD listen I thought it was obnoxious
to hire oh sure sure so yeah I did put
JD in charge at first JD you're in
charge of keeping the optic white but no
one listens to JD he doesn't command
respect just look at me laugh at me I go
what the [ __ ] you can't shush people I
tried man he'd go to me by our time I
searched for anyone there already
committed a bad act he was like Fredo
yeah that's when I hired a professional
sure sure she's former KGB by the way JD
you were really bad at it because you
know like it would be a little quieter
but then people would do [ __ ] and then
you were like oh sorry sorry yeah yeah
yeah on the other side of the wall like
we shared the same wall and I could hear
what you heard I think and on my own No
so I'm like running around and then I
don't see anything happen over there
they would commit a crime and then they
would get away with it because by the
time JD would get around there he could
you know he couldn't accuse them was
like the Keystone Cops he always missed
the key to being the shoe sure is you
got to catch the person in the act yeah
that's why this Russia has mirrors and
the Sher Shah has you know like it's
constantly roaming the hall there was
one day where like you needed to sleep
and you demanded I make sure things
happen
please go stressful half hours of my
life oh that's sure sure I hope she's
okay I called her the other day and I
said how are you she says listen don't
think my fishing skills are diminished
I'm staying at home with my family
shushing them just to stay sharp for
when we get back to New York